So let’s look at a coin. It has outcome 0-1 and
we’ve already learned that the probability
of the sum equals exactly K for N coin flips;
; looks like this cryptic formula over here:
N factorial divided by N minus K factorial and
K factorial. And then we had some other term here,
if the coin is fair, it is like 2 to the minus
N. Right now, I’m just going to care about these
coins over here. I won't care about the probability
for the time being. I want you to help me
construct a table for these counts as N gets larger.
So we start with N equals 1, go all the way to N
equals 4, obviously outcomes range from zero
all the way to 4 at 4 coin flips. So here’s our
table. It’s also quite obvious that these guys
over here can never occur: if you flip the coin
only once, the outcome can’t be 2. So we’re going
to fill out this table over here together for the
coin over here. Tell me, for N equals 1, what are
the two values that go right over here,
just those two values.